was at Hood but not somewhere else being
cuz I'm not need 21 yet what do you have
to drink um I had a
little drinks just a tiny one how many
of them did you have huh how many drinks
did you have just two and I had my third
one I finished my third one but
technically I was on my fourth one but I
had three of them so far I had all three
of them the cocktail mixed drinks what
kind of drink was it the uh adios um
uhhuh you had two of those
three of those my fourth one I was
technically just finished my third one I
had my third one like gone but I had my
third one on the
little the little thing for me and my
friend and then I had my fourth one I
was going to ask so you've had four so
far and then how many did you have after
that I had three but I was going to get
a fourth one you didn't finish it no
ma'am I didn't even finish it I even
started and did you drink anything in
the vehicle when you got in the vehicle
before you left no I just had that one
drink which wasn't um fully there which
just gone basically so it was like kind
of like warm but cold it see L besides
the drinking did you do anything else
any drugs no no that's just that one
drink that one Sonic
drink okay cuz you were passed out in
the car why did you fall asleep um
because I had passed out earlier today
um I was um didn't wake well I didn't go
to sleep this morning I stayed partying
um behind yes ma'am since what time you
know what time it is right now
um no last time I remembered it was 10:
in the um 10 at night but I was um over
here at Hooters and well not here at
Hooters I was over here driving you know
where you're at right now Water Burger
okay I had um what's it called I had
passed I remember I passed out pulling
up to the um sign she had to her ear
remember it was like 9:119 or Chris
Chris Chien mayonnaise so they took your
order yeah I had I just passed out this
always happens I just passed out as you
always pass out why even if I'm not
sober if I'm um sober as well I just
always come and I order and pass out I
can't always keep my eyes open most of
the time when I'm sober right now I'm
sober I don't know always um I pass out
anywhere and
everywhere by sober what do you mean as
in just drinking alcohol or um yes like
um just drinking alcohol because I was
called me my mom and my stepdad we just
got back from Wild this
weend so um this weekend for R we just I
ride with I rode with them my step um
stepdad rode my car or like drove my car
cuz we were I am Saturday um when I get
drunk I know how I get so like my mom
wanted to leave my car this weekend you
know how you get as in like when I drive
she didn't want me to like run into
someone else or like just has it
happened before um no CU when I'm
drinking she just doesn't want that to
happen cuz I had someone hit me when I
just bought my car so I just got my car
in April I just barely got that that was
my first car I ever got that I got that
on April 9 I bought my car in April 9 I
didn't get my car fully till the week
after which so you did have about three
drinks and a half tonight yes but I
didn't okay like so it's because you did
pass out right here in the
yes driver's seat I'm going to ask you
if you're willing to submit to some
field sobriety test because I need to
know if you're able to drive for you to
go home yeah you're willing to submit to
them well we'll submit to a sobriety
test okay so I'm going to have you go
ahead and stand over here that way we're
not over here M you have shoes or chunk
CLS yeah get those down at my um bottoms
for so I don't have anything
else no but
have is that those psyches did you drink
it no it's been there for a while yes um
after I was leaving the party it was on
the sidewalk and I didn't want the um
what's it called The Sidewalk to have it
I um the party was over there off of
behind um what's it called um Hooters it
wasn't um after the stoplight it was
right there in this um Hooters SP um and
the Hooters like distance between
Hooters or like between the light and
the Hooters stop light or I don't know
how to describe it and just snow it's
behind um Hooters and red circle no
steer Circle I don't know go ahead and
just put your shoes on for me so we can
walk over
there and just walk straight over
there I'm going to have you go ahead and
stand right here on this line
so you're willing to submit to the test
right yes
okay take she's taller than me I'm going
to have you go ahead and uh no I'm going
to have you follow the tip of my pen
with your eyes and your eyes only okay
okay
close
well cuz I'm not used to have except
this is my first car I've ever gotten
I've never had a car ever before this so
like the stuff that I have now is like
new to me so like me having my new like
my own car by myself me having my own
place by myself with my roommate it's
still new to me so like I don't know
just seeing it from far away I'm never
I'm still not used to it I don't know
it's still
weird it's but I'm still happy for it
cuz I still got it
myself I bought a TR hon La for Edition
on meal and it's my first car ever and I
got kicked out of high school I didn't
finish my first semester my senior year
so and for me getting that from just all
right so we're going to do the next test
okay you're standing in that straight
line you can see it right yes Ma I'm
going to have you go ahead and put your
left foot on that
line you're going to put your your right
foot in front of it touching Heel To Toe
with your eyes to your side you're going
to leave them on your side the whole
time do you understand yes oh my God I'm
you're going to leave them okay you're
going to leave them there what you're
going to be doing is you're going to be
taking nine heeled toe steps down that
straight line when you reach your ninth
step you're going to leave your lead
foot planted you're going to take a
serious of small steps back and you're
going to take another nine heel toe
steps down that line whole time you're
going to be looking at your feet go
ahead and put leave your hands to your
side you're going to stay in that
position until I tell you otherwise okay
whole time go ahead and stay in that
position how you work don't move from
there with your with your arms to your
side okay you may be still the first
time
okay okay so for this next test I'm
going to have you stand like this with
your arms to your side the whole time
you're going to remain in that position
unless I tell you otherwise okay you're
going to choose a foot of your choice
I'm going to be doing my right foot go
ahead and just stand there straight
don't move you're going to choose a foot
of your choice I'm going to be doing my
right foot you can do your left or your
right whichever you feel more
comfortable leave your hands to your
side please like this I put my should
raising just leave them to your side the
whole time okay I'm going to do my right
foot you can do whichever left or right
you're going to raise it about 6 in
above the ground parallel to the ground
whole time it's going to be parallel
you're going to keep your hands to your
side the whole time you're going to be
counting 1,1 1002 13 1004 until I tell
you to stop okay okay okay you may
begin 1001
[Music]
100178 lift it up 6 in above the ground
parallel
stop make a decision um I'm going to go
ahead and ARR sure I I filed out my H
CH all right ma'am go ahead and put your
hands behind your
back whatever I need and you have a
phone in there that need to come that
need to go um I have
there can't take a purse do you have a
wallet I in
there
first you go ahead and walk over here
toward quick can you put it in my my
hair behind my ear really quick this one
yes
ma'am thank you I just never been a rest
before this is
it I'm going to go ahead and just uh
sech you go ahead and step out really
quick before I know you have your your
shorts on but I'm just going to make
sure you go ahead and turn that
way I'm going to lift
your okay you go ahead and go back in
there yes sir thank you
all right listen to me I'm about to tell
you something important you're under
arrest for DWI the New Mexico implied
consent act requires you to submit to a
breath test to determine the alcohol
content of your blood after you take our
test you have the right to choose an
additional independent test if you
choose to take the additional
independent test you have the right to a
reasonable opportunity to arrange for a
physician a licensed nurse or laboratory
technician or technologist who is
employed by a hospital or physician of
your own choice to perform an additional
chemical test test the cost of this
additional test will be paid by the law
enforcement agency do you agree to take
our
test I need you to tell me yes or no yes
ma
okay
yeah thank
you go and walk that way
stre
go
now you go ahead and stand up
[Music]
okay
no
what are you
doing
[Music]
back just go ahead and stand right here
face the
wall
[Music]
how do I
receipt
go ahead and go ahead and put your feet
down that way you can get to the
other try to place the water little
F and I have to move them go over there
that way is it because they're in the Y
sorry okay put them behind your back now
oh you had
[Music]
him
there just go ahead and stand here
facing
keep me
in it's
coold I'm go ahead and go
in
this
you're going to the Detention
Center
what
yes
[Music]
just go ahead and face the wall
okay I'm going to take them off when I
take them off go ahead and put the your
hand up over your head okay do you want
to
put yeah they're going to come off I'm
going to have you take off your earrings
right now put your hand up
over
this one
too go ahead and take a seat I'm going
to have you um take off
your earrings if you can just take
[Music]
it